-You look amazing!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jimmy, I cannot with you.
You always give me
the best love.
It's the Virgo energy
for me every time.
-I give you that --
I wanted to say hi to the baby.
Hi, baby!
I cannot wait to meet you.
-The baby said, "What's up?
Can't wait to be besties."
-I love it, I love it.
I said, "Is there anything
I can get you?"
-You got me hooked up
with this back support.
-I got a pillow there.
You wanted a LaCroix.
-Thank you for
this LaCroix, honey.
-I got you a LaCroix.
I got whatever you want.
-Thank you so much.
Keeps the stomach settled.
You're really
looking out for me.
-I have to.
I'm so excited about this.
And, by the way -- You know me.
I love you so much.
-I love you, too.
-But when you announced it on
"Saturday Night Live,"
that was the best thing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You said, "Ta-da!"
-Yeah. Every time
I look back at that clip,
I'm like, "Why did I sound
like a villain?"
"I am..."
I don't know why I said it like
this, but I was so excited.
I mean, I always thought
to myself, you know,
I would love the opportunity,
obviously, to host "SNL."
I just did not know
it would be the same time
that I was pregnant.
And so I was like,
"I guess I got to say it."
-Yeah.
-I got to come out with it.
-You can't time that stuff out.
It's just everything magical
happened for a reason.
And it was the greatest --
I have a picture of you.
-Oh, my gosh! Yeah!
-The reveal.
It was just the best thing
I've ever seen.
It was so good.
Everyone went nuts.
Everyone went --
It was just great.
And, by the way,
you hosted a great episode.
You were unbelievable.
-Thank you so much.
-They loved you up there.
Everyone was like,
"Oh, we love Keke."
-I had so much fun.
I mean, I just felt like I was
really getting some real skills
going down,
I mean, from Steve to Lorne.
They were really just
giving it to me.
And all the cast.
I just felt really like
I was a part of a team.
-Yeah.
-And I love that.
I mean, from theater, with doing
Broadway and stuff like that,
I love to be a part of
a cast like that,
so it was awesome.
-Even from, like,
the first promo,
the commercial I saw,
I go, "Oh, no.
Keke's gonna destroy this one."
-You knew I was ready.
-Oh, yeah.
You got Kenan and Kel...
-Oh, my gosh! Yes!
-...to reunite.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So...
-Talk to me about this.
-Shout-out to Brian Robbins.
Obviously, shout-out to
Kenan Thompson, Kel Mitchell.
I grew up on "Kenan and Kel."
I've always loved that show.
And just the com-- I mean, I'm a
huge fan of multicam sitcom,
which we don't see
a ton of anymore, right?
-I miss it, I miss it.
-I miss it so much.
And just the satire
and the drama,
but also the heart of it all.
And it's so funny,
because, you know,
nowadays, whenever they
bring something back
or they -- you know, it becomes
this deep-seated drama.
And so I loved that when I came
to Kenan with the idea,
I was like, "Man, we should do
something like 'Kenan and Kel,'
but like 'Kenan and Kelly.'"
You know what I mean?
So I could be Kelly.
-Smart.
-And he immediately,
like, got on it,
you know,
wrote this great sketch
with his writing partner
over at "SNL."
And they came up with
this really funny sketch,
which is what you guys saw.
-Was Kel always in it?
-So, I didn't mention Kel.
That was a surprise to me.
When he -- When I actually
read the sketch,
I'm like, "You got Kel."
-Oh, my gosh.
-I'm like, this --
'Cause Kel is it!
You know what I'm saying?
Like, You think about Kel --
I mean, first of all,
Kel is another Virgo, like us.
From Chicago.
We're from the same city.
So I was so excited to get the
opportunity to work with Kel.
And I was actually in
the real throwback story.
Like, it was
a dream come true for me.
-I mean, you crushed it.
-Thank you.
-Now I'm thinking --
Speaking of Virgos, baby --
do we know what --
I know you're into signs and --
-Exactly. So, my baby is either
going to be a Pisces or Aries.
I'm not sure exactly.
Like, I mean, Pisces --
Let me know, guys.
I mean, Pisces are known
to be very deep.
They're emotional creatures.
So I just want to make sure I'm
not too blunt for my baby boy.
I don't want to be too --
-No.
-You know, I don't want to be
like, "Look, what's up?"
You know, I want to
make sure that I'm --
You know, because sometimes,
I can be a little too
"tell it like it is," you know?
I need to wade in the water with
a Pisces, wade in the water.
Just keep it chill, child.
-Keep it chill for now.
I'm just amazed
at everything you're doing.
I want to talk to you about
a couple things.
But this is
some recent highlights
that happened this year
with Keke Palmer.
-What ya gonna tell me?
-Well, I'll tell you some stuff.
Your movie "Nope"
was named one of
AFI's Top 10 Movies of the Year,
by the way.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-You crushed it!
Couldn't take your eyes
off of you.
-Oh, my gosh, stop.
-You were named
Best Supporting Actress
by the New York Film Critics
Circle for "Nope."
Come on.
"New York Times" named you their
list of best actors of the year,
Keke Palmer!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
And you were nominated for
three NAACP Image Awards.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Oh, my gosh. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Keke Palmer!
-Jimmy, I cannot with you.
You're the best.
Thank you.
-I just kind of freak out
at all the cool things.
One of the awards
is for hosting "Password."
Come on, buddy!
-I was going to say,
and "Password," okay?!
-Come on, buddy! Come on, bud!
-Exactly. That's us.
-That's my favorite.
It's so much. I love it.
Let's talk about this podcast.
-Oh, yes.
"Baby, this is Keke Palmer."
-"Baby, this is Keke Palmer."
What do people expect
when they listen to this?
-So, they can expect --
I mean, I think one of
the biggest things about me --
anybody that knows me --
is I'm extremely curious.
I love to ask questions.
And so you're going get
a bunch of different topics,
from dating to, you know,
how we, you know,
live in this world
with social media.
How do we grow?
How do we live with
being pregnant?
Like, just all of
these different experiences
that we're going to be having.
But the thing that I love
the most about getting to do
a podcast is that I also get to
have long conversations
and, most importantly,
with experts,
with some people that actually
specifically are in
some of these fields.
I'm always trying to get
into their heads.
You know what I'm saying?
-Yes, of course.
-Like, let me get
Neil deGrasse Tyson on.
What is really out there, Neil?
-Yes. Talk to us.
-Let me talk to Tom.
Did you realize what you were
doing when you created Myspace?
I want to know the truth.
-Tom from Myspace.
-Let me call up
the pastor and say,
"What's really going on
in the church?"
-Ooh!
But you do -- you get in there.
-Yeah.
-And people will tell you.
-Yeah, they do. They do.
I get so many --
I mean, I just had a --
this really great
dating expert on there,
who I was talking to, and I had
this big question like,
"What do you do when someone
comes to you and they're like,
'I'm really picky'?"
You know you guys hear that
all the time.
"Oh, I'm really picky.
You know, it's always just --
You know, it's hard for me
'cause I'm really picky."
And she said,
one of the biggest things
when someone tells her that
they're really picky,
the first thing she thinks is,
"You really don't know
what you want."
That's, like, the biggest sign.
When someone says they're picky,
a lot of times,
it's because they really
actually don't know how to --
They don't know how to narrow
down what it is they really want
and what matters to them,
so they just say,
"I'm really picky."
And then she said,
on top of that,
it makes her think that,
"Are you really actually willing
to do the work that it takes
to open yourself up to someone?"
And, so, you just kind of coax
it with, "I'm picky."
But, really, it's because
you don't really want to do
what it takes.
And, so, I was like --
I mean, I just --
It's something casual,
but when you really
get in deep down into it --
I mean, I have a homegirl
that's always saying she picky,
and deep down,
I know she ain't looking
for no man.
-Yeah.
-She ready to go to work.
-Yeah, you got to put
the work in.
You got to put the work in.
And then talk to me about
this digital TV network.
-Oh, yeah. So, KeyTV.
So, yeah, you know,
I've been in the industry
at this point -- it's so crazy
to believe -- 20 years, man.
-Is that right?
-20 years,
your girl been working!
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, 20 years
I've been in the industry.
And I think, just for me,
I kept thinking to myself,
"What can I do
to get outside of just me?"
I think, obviously,
as you know as an entertainer,
everything is always about you
and what the next gig
I'm going to do
and how I'm going to do this
and how I'm going to do that.
And I think
I just thought to myself,
"Okay, with the skills
that I've acquired thus far
and the different experiences
I've had as an actor,
as a producer,
you know, hopefully growing
into a writer and director,
how can I transcend that
into something outside of myself
for, you know,
my generation or my peers
and other people
that want to do
what I want to do?"
And so that's where
KeyTV came from.
It's the keys to
the culture, okay?
We're speaking to
the generation,
the Gen Z, Millennials
that want to do --
that want to be in entertainment
but don't know exactly
how to get there.
So it's about entertainment,
great content,
hopefully, if you check it out,
but then also
education and
the democratization of how to
actually get from
point "A" to point "B."
-Yeah, let's make some stars.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's make some stars.
You know what I mean?
Let's do it.
-I love that.
I love everything you do.
Keke and I are playing
a game when we come back,
"The Jinx Challenge."
-I can't wait for this.
-Come on back and get ready
for this. Come on.